good morning to you guys from Windsor I
am so excited to be here and as you know
we've got breaking news for you right
off the top it was just released just a
few minutes ago that Prince Charles will
walk Megan Markel down the aisle that is
a big breaking news development right
here and everybody is talking about it
outside but can I just say this to you
first I have such a bad case of royal
wedding fever and I'm not the only one
it hit me the minute I stepped off the
plane from the moment you get into the
airport there were so many people that
were excited just to be in line for the
customs but I have to tell you something
about our location when you look over
the shoulder that is Windsor Castle that
is where the wedding is going to take
place and we spent time in st. George's
Chapel a little bit later on we'll have
story on that so later on they've got a
rehearsal that's coming up but I want to
tell you this Roxana Saberi we have
correspondents all over the city we're
going to go now to Roxana Saberi who's
got the latest on the turn of events
with the drama involving Meghan Markel
and who will walk her down the aisle
Roxana to you good morning Gail Megan's
mother is set to meet the Queen here at
Windsor Castle today and royal fans are
ready to celebrate the big day now that
we know who will walk the bride down the
aisle
13 years after Prince Charles had his
marriage to Camilla parker-bowles
blessed at st. George's Chapel Hill now
walk his future daughter-in-law down the
same aisle Prince Charles has met Megan
Markel on multiple occasions including
last December at Christmas service with
the Queen the bride's decision to have
her fiance's father by her side on
Saturday and days of speculation
starting when her own father who was
supposed to take on the role was caught
up in controversy over these photos
thomas Markel senior told TMZ he staged
them to show himself in a positive light
he's now recovering from surgery after a
heart attack normally there isn't this
much drama going on before a wedding
normally it's much smoother machine and
normally they don't have their message
hijacked by celebrity gossip websites
royal correspondent Roy Anika says the
palace tried to protect Megan's father
from the press have you heard any
criticism of Kensington Palace in terms
of they should have helped Megan
Merkel's father more to prepare for the
wedding yes I mean kenton Palace have
come under fire for this my
understanding is that a lot of help was
offered from very early on the problem
has been and the issue has been getting
him to accept that help Donna Werner
flew in from Connecticut and has been
camping out across from the castle since
Tuesday no it won't ruin it but it
certainly I think will put a damper on
it on the days leading up to it